Brendan Hayward the former NBA player
former Tar Heel now on NBA analyst he
joins us on the program hey feeling
today um not feeling great at the door
the form of cardio today not feeling
great all right now take off your Tar
Heel hat and I want you just to look at
this as an analyst the the final play
good and bad I want you to critique it
the final play I think Bryce Johnson
really could have I'm not sure about i
think the course of the game plans him
to be farther back for a long past and
he wanted right to protect the basket
just in case that happen i would have
liked to see as an analyst the neutral a
nurse i would like to see soon as the
ball came inbound you saw wasn't a deep
ass i would like to see Bryce step up a
little bit more and get closer to
Jenkins so he doesn't get to walk in
three he was essentially kind of
unguarded you know for God I can shoot
the ball you need to be kind of close
enough where you can touch his body it's
not Bryce's fault that's what he was
told to stand it was just it was a great
play by Jay Wright and Christian cos hit
a great great shot and you have to tip
your capital yeah with 4.7 seconds I
thought okay I can't let our chudai a
Cano just get into the front court he's
got to work a little bit to get into the
front court and i agree with you once i
have pressure on him Brice Johnson can
start to cheat up I want him it close to
the foul line at least the dotted line
there that he's going to contest a
jumper because we know they're not
getting to the hoop now because they
don't have the time so I didn't like I
didn't like the defense at all I and I
do think that North Carolina almost felt
like they had wanted by tying it and
knowing they're going into overtime they
sort of like they drifted through those
final 4.7 seconds we think I don't they
drifted through the final four seconds
because everything else is pretty good
they did get a little bit of pressure on
our chiaki no I'm here he got out I
think a rub screen former chef foo on
Hicks kind of made it clouded it up Ryan
arch deokman was gonna be able to get a
good shot off but the wait
play is designed for going to know where
they run it several times in the games
that's they even talked about it they
run that play all the time that's their
goal to play in the game arch deokman
came through and is able to pass the
ball back to Chris Jenkins and kris
jenkins being the great shirt he is
having a great shooting night I was able
to walk into a three so everything on
the defense was fine except for UNC
didn't get matched up with Kris Jenkins
at the end of that play who diz uh
Jenkins remind you of uh Jenkins Connor
he kind of reminds me of I'm ago I'm old
so i'ma go old-school kind of Oz ba3d
Dennis Scott he's not quite as good but
will you look at the the build in the
body and how he could go inside and
outside he can post up smaller players
but he has infinite range on his jump
shot he count reminds me a 3d yeah I I
like to uh I feel like Paul Pierce it
just it feels like he can get his shot
he's got you know a body there and he's
got range so I I didn't see Dennis Scott
but because Dennis Scott was just such a
great knockdown shooter but I saw a
little bit more of just the score and in
a Paul Pierce like yeah well he's so
much big I think I think dinner Scott
because they can both shoot and they
have similar builds but he doesn't move
like Paul Paul Pierce is excellent with
his footwork and getting by people
getting step back and things of that
nature Jenkins has uses more of his body
and that's why I said three that's why i
said 3d a little bit more Paul Pierce
had some of the best footwork the NBA
has ever seen would you rather lose like
that last last night or the way Oklahoma
launched in the semis III rather lose
well Oklahoma lost a the truth because
if you get if you get blown out like
that you're like you know what they
didn't beat me and that's that and you
go on about your business when you lose
a game like this for the rest of those
kids lives they're gonna be playing back
every minor detail the game try to hit
this free-throw maybe we win if I would
have made this defensive adjustment
maybe we win if the ref makes this call
and I thought the Russell bad both ways
I'm not going to be the UNC guide I said
it was just bad gets UNC but it was some
very visa or not these referees should
not be allowed to run all the NCAA
championship game but if you're a kid
you also think it hate me
Reformation this call may be I win the
game so if your unc there's a lot of
things going through your head in the
game within a game of that magnitude
that you're going to be thinking about a
second guessing basically your entire
life there they're always when the NCAA
tournament comes on they're always going
to flash back to this moment so I
definitely rather get blown out I think
that you had Grant Hill and Bill Raftery
talking about how some chick eat at
calls Jenkins got too early I I thought
I thought they were controlling a little
bit too much in the beginning there and
not letting him play it and I didn't
have any stake in the game at all
Brendan I thought it was a little ticky
tack I think Jenkins did get some ticky
tack fouls I think you and see got a lot
of ticky tack fouls up late in the shot
clock but as I said it's on air last
night as a player be consistent if
you're gonna call a ticky-tack be ticky
tack the whole game and I'll live with
that but you can't be ticky tack the
whole game and then down the stretch
again they look like they didn't want to
call anything they started letting guys
get hacked and if the game's gonna be
wrapped in the physical manner let it be
reppin the physical matter call it
physical the whole game or are we going
to call it a little bit closer to the
vest call it like that all game but you
can't call the game one way in the first
half and then totally change how your
calling the game in the second half
that's not fair to the players and like
I said this isn't a UNC Homer thing this
is but both ways i thought the reps were
not very very good at all Brice Johnson
did he get enough touches last night
Brice Johnson I don't think his touches
were that big of an issue for me um I
looked at what Jay Wright did
defensively they basically took his Jay
Wright has taken away essentially with
whoever the best player is on every team
throughout the tournament he took away
buddy hield he took away perry ellis
right they did a great job of running
Bryce I didn't think UNC handled that
very well though I think they could have
flashed the post went to a little
high-low action they tried it a couple
of times but their spacing was kind of
bad like when you see it came fronting
the post your big happy flash to the
elbow your weak side guard has to bottom
out all the way to the three-point line
and then you are like then you'll have
such great space and that you'll be able
to either throw the ball over the top if
they're still helping you be able to
swing it
for three or that the big man that
flashed will have a iso situation in the
middle of the court where you and see
bigs are very very good at taking
advantage of that I think that's
something that they'll look back and say
hey we missed that in game we really
could have done better on the front and
those fronts did take rights away you
know those fronts were huge for what
Villanova did defensively and limiting
what how UNC gets points in the paint
Brendan Haywood the former Tar Heel
former NBA player by the way Shaq and
iverson going in in this year's class in
the Hall of Fame bigger impact on the
sport Iverson heard Shaq you played
against both right yeah I mean Shaq's
had a huge impact that's because of what
he did winning championships and
everything about nature Iverson for me
growing up Iverson was basketball for
for young african-americans in a pop
culture he was uh he was corn rolls when
cornrows wasn't cool back in the day he
was the big baggy jeans and the chains
and he was unapologetically himself you
saw it last night everybody else was
there in a suit on I was out loud he was
there with 75 gold chains on a t-shirt
in a as a baggy jeans that's who he is
and he meant he meant to he meant a lot
for a lot of people of my generation so
Shaq definitely had private a bigger
impact on the court the championship
speak for themselves but as for just
basketball culture for somebody in my
era it's allen iverson he he was
basketball you're doing a great job and
would love to have you on again to talk
the NBA but thank you for joining us
Brendan I well thank you very much for
having me I appreciate I love your show
to my you do an excellent job man Thank
You Brendan Brendan Haywood the former
Tar Heel the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience